there are some on the left who have  reacted by saying fundamentally these  people are no different than the  Marjorie Taylor greens and the most  extreme of the Republican Party While  others believe no there is an important  difference between people like McCain  and Romney and those that have taken  over the party now do you believe that  the difference is a materially  significant difference  there's a difference  and  McCain had whatever you think about his  policies I didn't like him I mean  but nevertheless he was sort of a human  being decent human being in some ways at  some degree of Integrity yeah that's  disappeared from the party I mean when  you look at them now they're virtually  all  cowering and Terror before the Trump  Rebel you can just see it in every act  that they make